let me take him as a bee before me help
me doing my job so they can't
thank you very much
nice to meet you I'm doing a daily vlog
suburban
good to see you how are you
good job yes taking us to make a show we
all see I'm Gary Vaynerchuk using my
partners and something dollars okay I
also run a 600 person digital social
shop that's you yeah I've been a fan
since probably age of 10 when I convert
it from a Giants fan pretty Co tight
know where those are [ __ ] years Oh awful
real pleasure I should say well after
the interval at a class talk about you
got a class down this thing so all right
we will be in touch yeah thanks man
three years actually even do it six
years ago she responded thank you that
it dad
yeah and a lot of you I know and the
it's like my good luck charm actually I
never time I should like I will never
tie my shoes shirt didn't bail maybe
like in the third grade
but I never trip and fall and high
to get bad luck stop I'll tie it like
when I sit down later but I'll never
time it noticing that it's a time is
precious funny that's exactly what I
think it is I think it's a time
what's good follow me on snapchat at
Lois new Friday and Sundance yeah
is it am I not touching it like what's
the what do you want to do is you're
just gonna hang with or wood and then
layer no calls or so - well Thursday you
have a couple of things will you get
there on Thursday and then you have a
video chat for that pitch yeah so that's
the only thing I usually don't touch you
can pitch me on something then of course
of course it's Australia - hello
Honolulu but this is what you need to
look at five hours layover so you're
just sitting and then to do is that
where I'm going to New York now as of
right now Lauren you go to South Africa
but you Cotto it's completely up in the
air you know what I mean yeah okay well
it has to be that day oh we got the
second or so trip in April in May in May
with second Australian right so actually
going do that get me home okay
cuz I mean this what can I do in a
five-hour layover and go and Hawaii
Allah well there's also a nine-hour
supposed to be talking in these things
you just broke the wall I'm weirded out
today okay this morning we got another
day hey maybe - so nice to meet you
Kelsey Humphries this is my husband
Chris I dragged him along I know I have
the hard to stop someone let's go fast
yeah I positive start a few minutes late
you started selling and having success
in sales as a kid so I mean let me
extend right yeah it was not like really
young right like now I like my daughter
six now she's in first grade I was
already really selling Wow so when I
look at her in her classmates it like it
was a weird kid they're gonna give us
ten percent of revenue ticket sales some
point towards focus afterwards and I'll
put up on the additions of for those
fantastic just trying to build one big
event rather than like two and a half or
three okay Alex how's business
what are you doing
how's your day going hey how are you sir
good to see you
okay good how long can we go till today
uh what was I said seven great so that's
a good time let's look we should narrow
do some damage yeah what up Facebook
d-roc I know you love perfect lighting
but eat it we're going this way
old school Wine Library TV 2007 style so
I just want to add a little color to
this episode about the audio book itself
opportunity for me to like create some
clarity on what exactly I'm doing really
excited about not just creating a book
that you know is a replica of the
questions and answers from the show
especially because even before Kaling
about other audiences or new audiences I
want to deliver for my core audience the
people that support me the people that I
bring free value to every day beer I'm
gonna go when the chapter begins you do
the reading of sort of the introductory
material when the questions pop up
review the answers so in fact we get as
much out of the book as your you'll be a
little bit concerned like what we ended
with yesterday was really good yeah the
only vulnerability is possibly just
leaving out a little oomph to make it as
deep as possible right and it's that
what I want - yep cuz they know you
answer it as if it's it I think with the
clips learning it helped me make it a
little beefier the number of that's
really in the third in the early fourth
quarter right towards the tail end I
think I was leaving a little off when
you made that comment I finished off
strong good you agree yes yes thank you
the real play here was a lot of new
questions categorizing themes that have
happened over 175 episodes ironically
there's almost three answers to every
question that's come through down
there was the answer I gave on the show
there's the answer that I was able to
dramatically expand on or tweak or even
update in the book and now that I'm
recording the audio book I'm kind of
freestyling on top of that so it might
be fun for people in the future to ask
me to create clarity on three different
answers though I have a funny feeling
that maybe one question through the
whole book because the fact the matter
is the matically they and even in detail
they should all match up and so very
very excited about it excited about the
continuation of dramatic content value
execution
I'd like to switch your mindset I'd like
you to think about supermarket right so
supermarkets if you think about how
they're laid out they have the
essentials on the opposite sides right
they try to make you go as far as
possible to milk because almost
everybody coming and there is gonna buy
milk now they don't block it you know
they may make it kind of inconvenient
and so I would say there's a very fine
line on a website from a ui/ux the
layout of your site are you gonna do
four pop-ups before they get to what
they want you know you're gonna lose
them by pop-up number two there's a way
to find that perfect Mendoza line
between value for you and value for them
where they put the milk I know it's
brilliant so if you want a hockey team
you a few hockey - oh I've been a
snapchat coma for two months already two
weeks I've been I'm ready to go let's
say you owned a hockey team what would
you do with snapchat I love this so
first of all if I owned a hockey team
hopefully be the New York Rangers let's
start with that I would understand that
what snapchat offers me right now this
recording early 2016 is enormous
opportunity to win the heart and minds
of 13 to 30 year olds in America and
really shape the minds of 13 to 18 year
olds and so what I would do is I would
take a step back and say cool I know
what the Rangers stand for I know what I
want people to think about the Rangers
but the problem is you can't talk to a
16 year old about the Rangers the same
way you're gonna talk to a 42 year old
and so I would try to think about what's
the cross-section of relevancy right for
example I would create contests on our
snapchat stories about date night for
high school kids right high school kids
care about dating that's kind of cool
and so having great seats against the
glass to impress that girl that you've
been chasing your whole life and finally
she's giving you a date that's cool
that's a quick way to go viral in
Westchester amongst potential New York
Ranger fans so what I would do is I
would kind of literally talk about what
it by the way this makes me take another
step back real good job by the order of
these questions I would go back to what
I just talked about first I would think
about the audience and their psychology
on snapchat they like silly things it's
fun
I would not over produce content I think
one of the biggest mistakes right now
brands and individuals are doing is
they're trying to make their snapchat
without contact too fancy too good of
lighting to this is not a Hollywood
blockbuster people want quick raw talent
you know just quick
I would I would take a video of Henrik
Lundqvist but the lighting was bad you
could kind of not even make out King
Henry like you know I would make it very
authentic and real and I would use it as
if I was a 16 year old boy and but that
would be the rangers account and then I
would entice them with if they watch the
story to the end to get that full
engagement there was ways to enter
contests that brought them value so I
would I would treat the platform the way
it's supposed to be treated and then I
would create incentives around the
psychology of that audience based on
things that I could bring them value and
to me the dating culture is kind of neat
so thank honestly I just can't wait to
get the stories in a year or two from
everybody that read askgaryvee and had
success from it very honestly it just
reminds me a lot more of crush it than
anything else in a weird way askgaryvee
is is really a crush at 2.0 a real you
know kind of imprint of how to do it
through the questions and answers and so
I'm kind of getting impatient I'm kind
of getting antsy waiting for 2018 2019
that's
titled your book changed my day
you